seules éoliennes marines en france
contre 400 en mer du nord
mais pourquoi tant de retard la france
c'est pourtant 3500 kilomètres de côtes
et plein de promesses
va-t-on bientôt revoir une forêt
d'éoliennes au large du tréport
mais ça finit souvent comme ça les
éoliennes en mer reste un mirage des
projets tomber à l'eau ou reportés alors
que les premières éoliennes marines
d'europe existe depuis 1994
en france elles ont toujours eu de
farouches opposants on ne va mon horizon
comme ça on empêche de rêver des
riverains des élus mais surtout des
pêcheurs on apporte quelques paires que
vu l'étendue de ce parc c'est cette zone
de pêche niçois ne soit retiré quoi et
depuis ça traîne alors qu'en 2010 le
danemark a déjà deux fermes d'éoliennes
opérationnel depuis dix ans il nous
encourageait à l'heure à leur emboîter
le pas
la france doit commencer dès maintenant
à se préparer et doit former les mains
d'oeuvres spécifiques capables de
travailler dans des conditions qui sont
quand même des conditions très spéciales
danemark royaume uni pays bas les pays
autour de la mer du nord concentre 71 %
de la production éolienne marine en
europe quant aux pays qui donne sur
l'océan atlantique comme l'espagne et la
france c'est seulement un petit pour
cent
las de toute évidence chez schéma
industriel et l'a fait flop mais il ya
d'autres problèmes techniques cela en
comparaison avec la mer du nord la zone
atlantique et - venteuse et surtout
l'eau est plus profonde
la solution alors c'est l'éolienne
flottante beaucoup plus cher en 2016
un prototype testé au large de porto
était prometteur ça maintenant on fasse
très commercial donc on va commencer la
phase plus industrielles on va
construire trois unités
la première éolienne flottante de france
est opérationnelle depuis octobre 2018
en attendant que d'autres soit importé
le pays est parmi les plus petit
producteur d'énergie éolienne marine
loin derrière l'allemagne et le royaume
uni
[Musique]